merci michel on va parler maintenant de
l'aspect scientifique de tout ça donc
des feux de forêt en californie qui sont
maintenant les plus meurtriers de
l'histoire de l'état bien que cet état
est connu un nombre anormalement élevé
d'incendiés depuis dix ans bien ceux des
derniers jours sont vraiment
exceptionnelles renault bonjour bonjour
merci d'être avec nous ce matin
donc contrairement à ce que dit donald
trump s'est pas nécessairement liés à la
gestion des autorités sur place qui se
passe dans le pot la gestion des
autorités sur place et les feux de forêt
dans cette région là on en fait en temps
normal la californie c'est frais ça
s'étend de l'ami du milieu de l'été
jusqu'à là au milieu de l'automne on
dirait vraiment que la californie est en
train de brûler à l'année longue et les
dégâts sont de plus en plus considérable
avec les années qui passent il ya eu
cinq mille feux en californie en 2018
c'est énorme
il ya plusieurs raisons derrière tout ça
c'est sûr que une des raisons
principales c'est les changements
climatiques sont vraiment le moteur qui
alimente toute cette réaction mais il ya
d'autres raisons qui explique l'étendue
des dégâts
d'abord il ya l'étalement urbain à la
limite de la région forestière qui
vraiment au sud une étude de 2013 que
montré que jusqu'à 25% la population
californienne vivaient dans ces régions
boisées où les risques d'incendié ont
explosé au cours de la dernière décennie
mais en plus de tout ça les feux des
derniers jours sont d'une énorme
intensité alors plus fort il pouvait
brûler jusqu'à 30 hectares chaque minute
pour avoir une intensité comme ça il
faut vraiment des conditions extrêmement
particulières
justement quelles sont elles ces
conditions là pour qu'un feu de forêt et
il se débrouille bien là et bien il faut
qu'ils aient besoin de trois choses
avant un climat chaud et sec
des vents forts mais aussi une énorme
quantité de plantes sèches les plantes
sèches c'est un problème qu'on trouve
partout en amérique du nord parce que au
cours du dernier siècle
on a vraiment combattu beaucoup les feux
de forêt c'est normal on peut comprendre
mais en faisant ça on a contribué à
l'accumulation du nomes quantité de bois
mort ou d'une homme quand il de petits
buissons qui quand le temps devient
chaud et sec comme avec les changements
climatiques ça devient une véritable
poudrière le moigne poule à - 9 la neige
puis le front peut prendre la danse et
facilement à seurre faut ajouter une
conditions assez particulières de la
californie qui sont les vents de santana
soucier des vents très forts qui
viennent des régions désertiques de
l'ouest des états unis
il traverse l'état à chaque automne et
suivant leur peuvent non seulement
alimenté le brasier mais aussi pousser
les braises des fois des kilomètres plus
loin que le feu principal et démarrer
des nouveaux foyers
et là vous l'avez mentionné à 30
hectares à chaque minute
on a vu ça au cours des derniers jours
sarah le combat extrêmement difficile
pour les sapeurs effectivement des
comptes tant que le feu est petit il est
peut être facile à prévoir parce qu'il
est très dépendant des conditions météo
on peut regarder où les vents vont aller
puis on se prépare en conséquence
mais dès qu'on prend une certaine
ampleur il va commencer à créer sa
propre condition météo une forêt ça
brûle à des températures entre 700 et
1000 degrés celsius
donc ça ça va envoyer une énorme
quantité d'air chaud dans les airs qu'au
niveau du sol s'est offert un appel
d'air qui peut créer des vins d'environ
90 km et 6 vent là ça peut changer la
trajectoire d'un feu de forêt à
n'importe quel moment
donc le feu s'alimente par l'humain je
lis élémentaire l'humain il peut changer
de trajectoire de façon complètement
aléatoire
donc c'est pour laisser sociale des
choses qui peut arriver en ce moment
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour prévenir
ces feux là en dehors de revoir notre
façon de gérer l'île et bâtiments dans
les régions à risque la méthode qui
serait la plus efficace ce serait de
faire plus de feux contrôlés
donc ça c'est des feux de forêts qui
sont déclenchées par les pompiers
eux-mêmes pour éliminer ces aveux ce
ticket ce bois martinez [ __ ] petit
intensité qui vont pas brûler les grands
arbres et en faisant son veau nettoyer
les forêts et les rendent moins fragile
face à ces méga incendies et des yb est
le feu par le feu c'est exactement soyez
des études qui ont montré que les forêts
qui ont été nettoyées de cette façon là
sont bons les flancs des feux de forêts
qui vont aider la traversée les flammes
vont être moins intense
les arbres les grands arbres vont
survivre davantage en a moins qui vont
brûler et c'est ça qui va faire que
l'incendié va être beaucoup plus
facilement contrôlable et ce qui rend
tout ça très exceptionnel aussi c'est
qu'on est en dehors de la saison
habituelle en californie la saison
habituelle comme je les dis c'est
vraiment elle elle se termine à la
mi-octobre mi octobre donc là on est
rendu au moins deux familles novembre
avec un incendie de cette intensité là
ça c'est vraiment quelque chose qui sort
de l'ordinaire et ça on peut le relier
au changement climatique
merci beaucoup de nous mais ça fait
plaisir